or when you have yourself a villain
who's pretty much an 80s cartoon
personified in human form be it animated
you should have a win on your hands
should Despicable Me 3
so this pickup of Me 3 is the third
installment in the despicable Me
franchise for to be count the minions in
this movie there's a lot that happens
but the gist of it is GRU and his girl
lose their jobs at the agency with a
villain named Balthazar Brad who steals
a diamond GRU finds his long-lost twin
brother little girl looking for a
unicorn and the minions are in prison a
lot happened in this movie first of all
talk about what I like there were a
couple things that did make me laugh one
was when the minions were all in jail
they're pretty much running the joint
when they were in prison that did crack
me up and Balthazar brat any time he was
on screen I loved it he's voiced by Trey
Parker from South Park he has a lot of
physical comedy he like moonwalks well
Michael Jackson music playing moon walks
across the water dude is everything
about the 80s wrapped up in an
abomination 80s really interesting
entertaining time perfect to do in
satire and this movie does it well in
the form of a villain however although
he as the villain cracks me up and he
entertained me when he was on screen he
kind of got pushed in the background
because the despicable Me movies at its
core are not about heroes and villains
they're about family come over the
family dynamic while interesting kind of
fell flat to granny GRU meets his
long-lost twin brother and I thought
that an interesting thing to do in a
movie like this and they have some fun
because dude if I ever found out I had a
twin the long-lost twin it'd be like I
do YouTube how about we split it up to
where I do half the videos you do the
other half and we just have more free
time let's do some fun [ __ ] or maybe it
did happen maybe this is the other main
I don't really know I feel like a lot of
people think about what would they do if
they found a long-lost twin brother and
they do have some fun with that premise
in this movie but really in the end they
only have some fun and they have to move
on to some other things because this
movie tries to do so much and that's
always the Trouble Man when you put too
much in a movie nothing can really shine
example in the world where group finds
his long-lost twin brother there's some
opportunity with that to go places so
they never really go there they don't go
the emotional route you would expect in
Despicable Me 3 the despicable Me movies
really revolving around I was right
family example there's a scene where
Gru's brother was talking about how he
was disappointing in the eyes of his dad
and you know that GRU is
disappointing in the eyes of his mom so
they could have had a conversation about
like maybe we're not disappointing maybe
they are would have been a great moment
for the two of them but they never
really go there what are these guys
Despicable Me 3 I feel like it'll be
fine for families it's better than cars
free I could tell you that entertaining
parts in it chuckle worthy parts there
were parts where I laugh but there are
few and far between though and a lot of
times I was just like I'm bored I never
really heard the kids in the audience in
the theater belly laugh either there
were a lot of kids a lot of families
there a couple of chuckles like what I
didn't get the feeling anyone was like
yeah that's the [ __ ] you're like walking
out people could be like well it's cute
for families it is cute for family
doesn't make the movie good though you
just can't help but see the missed
opportunities here I guess this is a
movie for kids I'm not looking for
Macbeth or anything but if I can just
think back to the movies and cartoons I
enjoyed as a kid they had a point in
purpose to him if this movie just
focused up something would have shine
but as a sense nothing really did in the
world where you're looking for something
like a pacifier for your kids you need
to lock them into a movie for the
weekend you just want to have family
night out I think the movie is fine for
that
it's no secret I've never been on the
despicable Me train as much as a lot of
other people maybe I'm the curmudgeon
his [ __ ] here don't know all I know
is when I walked out of the movie I was
thinking to myself he probably would
have been a better time with a shot of
warm milk at night yeah and now it's a
party it's the kids movie come on let's
have some class right guys so Despicable
Me 3 have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]